hi guys my name is al PO Belson and
today I'm going to speak about how you
can get to know any data set in four
lines of item so let's imagine a
scenario you and a data set walk into a
bar
so we have our account table and you
really want to understand what it
contains so the most probable strategy
that you will take is to just query a
lot of questions like how the revenue
column is distributed what is the
minimum and maximum values how many
missing values do we have and do the
same for size and country but that's
just not the way to do it
so what's wrong it's time-consuming it's
certainly not fun it's a Volpone and
some of the questions may require a lot
of skills like if you want to say what's
the correlation of size and revenue so
there must be a better way and there is
we're gonna utilize pandas and it's
amazing gecko system to automate the
post the process as much as possible so
this is an amazing reliability that
automate 90% of this world
it's called pandas waffling and it
creates an HTML report of all the
question that you might have on a data
set so what's this snippet we start with
a data set whether it's a file sees a
table
we then read it to a panda's data frame
whether with read CSV or with sequel
depending on your time and then the
one-liner the tuple the magic is pandas
waffling dot o file report this generate
HTML that give us all the answers if you
want to render it in Jupiter you just
keep it as if and if you want to create
an HTML file you write to file so I will
show an animation of
previous and what generated hold the
previous slide so in the top right you
can see table of content and I will
start going overland so we have an
overview of our dataset and I remind you
it's automatic so we have the number of
valuables we have 13 columns we have 800
rows we have statistic on missing values
duplicate and the size and now the
variable types are distributed so this
dataset is the Pokemon dataset phone
column so it's a bit cleaner than you
would expect most of the dataset so the
first thing that you will see is
warnings like the second morning is that
the type two of the Pokemon has a lot of
missing values and this is the most
crucial palette each will get a lot of
statistics how many distinct count how
many missing values in placenta average
minimum maximum how many zeroes if you
toggle for details you can get the most
common values and extreme values in
histogram quantum statistics and
descriptive statistics of course if its
category available you will get
different types of metrics specifically
here we don't have a lot of categorical
one next we have the correlation part
which required a lot of skills many
people will probably just skip it so we
have different type of populations for
example you can see here that the number
of the pokemon i'll correlate with the
generation it become it belongs to you
can see in the red stone dead
IVA so there is another section here but
I won't go over it because I don't have
time which is correlation of missing
values and there are two more libel is
that I want to show you there are less
crucial but they can be useful there is
PivotTable GS which allows you to create
interactive pivot tables to slice your
dataset and see the distribution and
aggregation so this is again the snippet
only additional line and yet again we
start with a data set we did a panda's
data frame and create an HTML so if we
can see any animation of how the
accountable is distributed year over
year across different industries you can
choose how to visualize it whether as a
it map always a bottom and it can be
really time-saver
instead of like writing it on your own
the last thing that I want to show you
is Phi D QC this library allows you to
compare two data sets so a useful
example is when you want to compare a
distribution of the training set and the
test set so again we start with data set
will lead them to memory and then we
plot the data set a bail image so we can
see in the right an example for for a
numerical one we have the plot that
compels them we have minimum of both we
have median we have mean in for example
it's a data set they just copy the same
the same data but on different time and
on the left you can see the time itself
so we have the maximum and the minimum
and the plot itself so there is no
silver bullet because
pandas shine on non nested data set so
you might need to write more than four
lines of Python if you have a nested
JSON for example also pandas requires a
lot of one because you load it in memory
so for most use cases it will be enough
to just sample the data set but there
are more tweaks that you can do on the
type itself and the last thing there are
some question that may arise that you
will need to just write code to answer
them like if you want to see our clients
across different columns and that's it
[Applause]
[Music]